joining us here on the rich eisen show
from pro football talk which starts our
day and pft
pm which ends our day right here on nbc
sports on peacock
every day is mike florio back here on
the show how are you michael doing great
rich how are you i'm doing fine are the
patriots uh
suddenly now free agent hawks that's
what we're looking at right now it's
that character
because previously it was like green bay
packers style
very rarely making a splash a daily
thomas and oh
seven are there about stephon gilmore
they usually don't go out and spend
market value
they had that cap space that they built
up last year
and they're spending it tight end johnny
smith i think that's huge when you keep
cam newton
it's one thing to keep cam newton with
the guys that you had on the field
around him last year if you're going to
upgrade
what you have on both sides of the ball
a team that was seven and nine you know
we think the patriots like when they
were three and 13 because it's so
rare for them to not be good no they're
not far from contention
they keep cam newton for the whole year
they have him
in the second season in the system the
covet stuff messed them up last year
this is a team that i think is going to
be written off by a lot of people now
making moves like this they're going to
get back on the radar screen but
this is the way that you spend that
money you spend that cap space they
definitely have the cash you know a lot
of the teams
have cap space but they don't have cash
because they lost a lot of money last
year
you know there are plenty of owners that
don't earn a lot of money in their other
lines of business but
robert craft doesn't have any issues
there he can pay these guys
and belichick spending the money and you
know i have a feeling they're going to
keep going and
the bargains are still to come that
that's what shocked me about this i
thought the patriots would just wait
and go out and gobble up a bunch of
bargains once the market softened for
them to be jumping in especially this
year and there's gonna be so many
bargains that's what surprises me the
most
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
let's get into the saints here
um as expected drew brees announces his
retirement and as expected as he
announced today on the today show he's
joining uh
the family that we're both part of nbc
sports
so um what next i mean
taysom hill that that contract certainly
caused me to refresh my screen a couple
of times the contract extension four
years 140 million dollars
but give me the layman's terms about
what the saints did here and what it
does mean for their quarterback scenario
moving forward i'll give you the floor
on this entirety of
the deal rich is fake they could have
picked any numbers they
wanted and it's not a coincidence that
they went with the 35 million dollar
average because that's the russell
wilson
average per year under his deal that was
not a coincidence
i'm told but it could have been anything
and the problem is
the way that it first came out and we
know how the sausage gets made reporters
do favors and they
they they will engage in some
liberties and it was just enough to get
people to think it's a four-year 140
million dollar deal and it's not
it's just a device for taking what he
was going to make this year
and spreading it out over five years so
they can pick up some cap space they
picked up 7.75 million in cap space i
asked somebody
what does tayson he'll get out of this
he gets two things one he gets all of
his compensation guaranteed
for 20 21 not that there was any doubt
he wasn't going to make it anyway and
two
he creates cap space so they can improve
the team around of course the irony may
be
the cap space they create pays for
jameis winston
to come back and compete with taysom
hill and potentially take the starting
job
so um couple things one
is why was uh it uh
not coincidental the number that they
just chose 140 million for a 35 million
dollar average for russell wilson did
they still
think that that's a possibility i think
it was more of a wink to
the reality that it's not a possibility
now look we don't know who has called
i think it would be incumbent on any of
the four teams that were flagged
by mark rogers who represents russell
wilson 17 18 days ago
to make that phone call and see
hypothetically
what it would take to get russell wilson
you have to do your due diligence
i think once you fully guarantee taste
some hills pay for this year
turn it into a signing bonus to create
cap space that means
hills gonna be on the team which means
he wouldn't be part
of a trade package most likely to get
russell wilson
which also means that they're not gonna
have both guys
not at those numbers on the roster
although russell wilson only has a 19
million dollar salary this year
that's one benefit whoever picks him up
gets it's not like they're inheriting
a huge cap number if they get him
because it's just 19. the problem is
what you're also inheriting
he's going to want a new deal at some
point especially in the aftermath of dak
prescott but i think the saints
aren't in now what they'll probably
announce the trade later today as i say
that
but i i just i don't see it happening
because i i there's no reason
to to do the taste of hill restructuring
if you're just going to send his
contract
to seattle and uh once they did that you
know
it's kind of like with what the cowboys
once they did theirs of course he's not
going there
once they do the restructuring of taysom
hill i feel like he's staying in new
orleans
and the saints are going to look
elsewhere and who knows maybe next year
they try to trade for russell wilson
if he doesn't leave seattle this year
and so
the hill and jameis scenario
we may not know who the saints are
starting at quarterback week one until
a training camp decision is that like
possible i mean look at look at what
they did and they managed to do it most
coaches can't pull this off where they
keep it close to the vest
until they're ready for people to know
who the quarterback is going to be
but that first week when drew brees
wasn't able to play with
28 broken ribs this year and we didn't
know is it winston is at hill
sean payton does a great job of keeping
everyone's mouth shut and we found out
it was hill
when peyton wanted us to know i think he
envisions peyton does a competition
between hill
and winston and we know that peyton has
the willingness to use both guys if he
thinks it's advantageous remember that
long
pass on the trick play that they stole
from the bears
in the division around lost to the
buccaneers that wasn't thrown by a hill
he's got the arm to throw it
they brought jameis winston and let him
throw it so i think he
let him compete and he'll use the best
guy and maybe use both guys
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
of the monday of free agency week in the
nfl in 2021 right here
on the rich eisen show um out of all the
quarterback situations to use our
phrase that pays in the nfl media um
pretty much every team that may need a
quarterback or
could change a quarterback or definitely
needs a quarterback
that's a large group of people uh and
teams mike
um you know every one of them could go
ahead and draft one
or hold on to who they currently have
with the exception in my mind of the
chicago bears
the bears could draft one at 20 but you
know who who are you going to get
potentially to just throw out there and
maybe catch fire for a coach and general
manager that's on the hot seat
um and uh you know
trubisky running it back with him even
though he's a free agent or
foals i don't think is tenable what are
they going to do i mean do they really
think that they can go ahead and
pry russell wilson loose with a pr
package that may include the water tower
i mean like what what what what is that
mike what do you got for me on that
front i just think it's going to be very
difficult for them
to put something on the table that will
get the seahawks to say
yes and when they restructured khalil
max deal
kicking some money from this year into
future years reducing his cap number
that seemingly takes mac out of the
conversation
the trade compensation to try to get
russell wilson i just think that if the
teams that have been identified it's
going to be hard to pull off now
the four teams identified i don't think
that's the full and complete universe
this is a gut feeling on my part
i think there may be some other teams
out there that mark rogers strategically
omitted
that could ultimately potentially get
involved in this and wilson would accept
the trade
but i think it's gonna be hard for the
bears and rich you mentioned the
possibility of using that 20th overall
pick
on a quarterback people will know
by the time the first round of the draft
rolls around whether or not the bears
are looking
and if they haven't addressed their
quarterback position in a way that
people will say oh that's definitely the
guy then you may as well have a sign
out in front of hallows hall that says
we're taking a quarterback
with the 20th pick so you better jump to
number 19 if you want the best guy who's
left
as the pick draws closer and closer to
us which isn't ideal either so
they're in a they're in a mess here and
i know there's a report over the weekend
they're moving on from mitchell trubisky
i'm told they haven't ruled that out
they've got everything on the table
and they're just going to see how it
plays out at some point though you've
got to move on if you're trying to get
russell wilson you've got to move on
from that
and go toward someone who you believe is
at least going to be your guy
for this year the thing about russell
mike is just
you know i we i guess don't know how bad
their
the relationship between coach carroll
and
and russell wilson really is right i
mean but
why would he want to leave a spot where
dk metcalf is there
and locket is there and no matter
what the protection may be you know
they're gonna run it right so
so you're not gonna be in a situation
like stafford who who never got a 100
yard rusher out i mean
and then you know you know bobby
wagner's gonna be there you know there's
some like
there's some people there you know that
can that can go ahead and
and win you some games like i wha
is it that bad that they're doing that
or they're just sending a signal up to
just
give an idea that it can get this bad
and you better fix it right now i mean
like what what is going on there
i think ultimately what he wants rich is
the offense to run through him like it
does with a patrick mahomes
and he doesn't believe it runs through
him they did it last year for a while
with the let russ cook thing and then
the defenses
caught up to what they were doing in
this new look offense and they did a
poor job of pivoting
away from what the defenses were doing
to slow them down there was that stretch
with seven turnovers by wilson in two
games and that was the moment according
to the athletic where he went in with
ideas
for how to improve the offense in
advance of the short week game against
the cardinals and they politely told him
no and he stormed out of the room
according again to the athletics so
i think plan a for him is give me what i
want
let let me be the offense let me be
patrick mahomes
and if you're not going to do that trade
me to a team that will i think that's
the play here so
he could very well stay and if the
seahawks don't get an offer they can or
won't refuse
he will stay but think about how
dysfunctional it will be you know i
always root for good stories and
obviously be a great story if russell
wilson got traded not for seahawks fans
be a great
be a great story for us wouldn't be a
better story if the entire year
is just one haze of dysfunction for the
seahawks weekend and week out
and every pete carroll press conference
and every russell wilson press
conference and how many times would he
say go hawks and how many times will he
say
not go hawks and it just it it it's they
have to ask themselves if we're
careening toward an
end when's the best time to remove the
band-aid do you peel it off slowly for a
season or just rip it off now and only
they know
whether or not they're comfortable going
forward with a year that could be a
complete mess
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
uh the bucks signing shaq barrett
long term levante david two-year deal um
brady extends
uh to provide cap relief that currently
uh for the team has chris godwin under a
franchise tag for the moment so
that keeps him off the market uh this
week what is jason light's to-do list
best you can tell right
here for a team that uh said they
thought they could resign everybody
well i gotta figure out what they're
gonna do with leonard fournette and that
may be a luxury they can't afford now
they're creating plenty of cap space
between brady and they got a
relatively low cap number for shaq
barrett south of 6 million
if you could extend chris godwin's deal
you create more cap space
so i look they've managed to keep so
far guys that he was kind of on the
fence what were they going to do with
chris goblin would they franchise tag
him if they didn't he was likely walking
away they don't tag shaq barrett
he doesn't walk away he resigns my guess
is they made it clear to him
you got an offer on the table until noon
on monday once the market opens we got a
bunch of other options out there at pass
rusher we're going to go start
signing them up unless you say yes he
said yes they still haven't dominic and
sue out there
gronk and a.b i assume if they play for
anybody
they're going to play for the bucks
although i don't rule out for example
the seahawks
getting in on a b because that's the guy
that russell wilson has clamored for in
the past
i don't rule out the packers getting in
on a b because that could be a guy that
aaron rodgers clamors for
gronk i think though if he plays for
anybody he's playing for the buccaneer
so i think that
it's down to sue leonard fournette and
then i think just a matter of time
before gronk and a.b
come back unless there's a curveball
that's thrown into the antonio brown
discussion and what are you hearing
about before i let you go because this
is
uh part and parcel of a free agency week
the draft and what you're hearing about
um about the jets sitting in that uh two
position
in that domino spot what are you hearing
about their
decision making and how that involves
desean watson potentially
in houston more and more i hear about
it's like forget about that joe douglas
is not going to
sell anything remotely close to the farm
required to get watson
who might not be interested in the jets
anyway what do you think about this uh
scenario that could affect um so many
other quarterback situations in the nfl
well one thing joe douglas the gm of
that team's been doing is building from
the inside out not the outside in
focusing on the line offensive and
defensive and
you had chris sims on your show last
week he's all over zach wilson
as in his mind the best quarterback in
the draft and if the jets see
in wilson what sim season wilson why
would you
try to trade for anybody else you get a
guy straight out of college
on a rookie deal where you can spend
around him
because you know you've got him on an
affordable contract relative to what
quarterbacks cost
and he could be the guy that the jets
have been
looking for ever since joe namath went
to the rams
so i i think that that it makes sense to
use the free agency
money to work on the offensive line and
for that second overall pick again it
comes down to how they feel about zach
wilson but sims is pretty
pretty strong on this and he's got a
good track record of spot in these guys
whether it's patrick mahomes or lamar
jackson or whoever and he's all over
zach wilson so
until i hear otherwise that's what i'm
that's what i'm keeping my eye on
use free agency for other positions and
go grab your franchise quarterback with
number two
so you know how the way this works um
and a road map
um for it would be what arizona did once
they
drafted kyler murray um and then traded
josh rosen
you know that deal wasn't made until the
friday night because you're not gonna
get rid of sam darnold even though you
love zach wilson until you
actually have zach wilson like zach
doesn't fall
and break his leg the day before the
draft of the morning of trying to get
out of his hotel room if that's the way
we could get back in the regularity uh
honestly in cleveland you know so
so who might be still in the market do
you think
uh for a quarterback the friday night of
the draft getting through free agency in
the first round could that be like the
bears dream scenario
that we i guess to bring this all full
circle like who do you think would would
be a market for sam darnold
on the uh if it is that late of a
trigger pull on the deal
i think that's another reason for the
jets to wait until after round one
because there will most likely be
one team standing all seats filled as
far as first round quarterbacks go
and so they're still going to be looking
and they didn't go all in
in free agency to get a guy who was a
clear answer or via trade
they didn't get the guy they wanted in
the first round of the draft so let's go
get
sam darnold and you get more if you're
the jets if you get a team that's
desperate
because they didn't get and remember
josh rosen got a second round pick
for arizona so yeah i think i think that
timeline makes sense whether it's the
bears whether it's the 49ers who've been
linked
to sam darnold and i think they hold on
to jimmy garoppolo until they get an
upgrade and then possibly cut him loose
because
25 million i think is more than than
what his current
skill and ability to stay healthy
justifies but
yeah i think sam darnold could be that
delayed reaction guy
this year after that that first day of
the draft you got an 18-hour window or
so
and the jets would make the most of it
and finding a partner for darnold mike
thanks for the time greatly appreciate
it as always
again you bet thanks mike florio check
out pftpm later on right here on nbc
sports on peacock cause
news is a break-in hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here